when do you notice a lot of demand for
the film when you start to see a lot of
activity with the movie um I used to in
the past it used to be more I did rely
on what we all assume which is one of
the guys has an article out or a movie
out if people are searching one of the
people in the film but then I'm actually
discovered that it's it's really when
the the filmmakers themselves are
actually promoting their own film out
there it's almost it never fails you
always have to keep promoting your film
so like with with my producer she's
always the days or the periods that
she's actually tweeting about the film
letting people know about it then you
start actually see that there is
interest and it really shows and the
days that you know you're busy and
you're not really doing that you start
to see actually the drop but to like
release your film and go well okay it's
out there it's on amazon is dystrophy
watch it sell i discovered that it just
doesn't work you really literally every
single day you have to do it and I
started to see more the spike because in
the past when you looked up an actor you
would come up with or here a couple of
movies that this actor is in and they
would click on a movie and then they
will buy it now you've gone to a point
where when you click on it you do a
Google search you're getting articles
you're getting a lot of YouTube videos
of them their kids you're getting
more promotions just from you know a
like an actual would have one movie that
is recent and I realizing that actually
the recent movie that they're in
completely wipes everything and always
the the studio's get the priority in the
search so if you're independent your
movie is going to be literally like in
page 65 buried underneath because they
give priorities to bigger companies so
you have to keep yourself more you have
to keep it interesting for the people
that search on the web and for your
audience you almost have to really
directly target your audience so it's an
everyday thing you can't just throw it's
a constant it's a constant unless you
have like millions of dollars and you
could buy billboards and by articles and
even magazines are not going to write
about your your film because you're
independent so it's either like you know
something happened on your set or when
you're selling your film and they're
interested in covering it but you know
magazine's cover studios and big
production companies they're not going
to cover your film so it's your baby you
have to literally every day tweet post
to message words let people know about
the movie because there are a lot of
people out there that would see your
film but but it's a lot of work but if
that's what it takes and you want to
sell your film you just have to let
people know about it yeah
and what direct advice can you give to
us for goodbye promise um to let people
know what the movies about to let people
know that the movie exists because it's
a great film and it's actually like when
I watched it man it's like that that's
an intense story that's a very intense
torrent it related to it I related to it
I saw every single one of us in our film
in your movie and it's almost like it
was uh it was a code language that we
all spoke in town here and in this
business that it like it made sense like
you know you guys would cut to a certain
scene and I'd be like all right I know
where this is going and it's like it
just very it moves you and I think
people that are interested in the
business need to really know that
because it's so easy for myself to say
well I made my big break you know you
know you directed goodbye promise you
release it but if people don't really
know what the content is and they don't
know where the movie is and they don't
know what the movies really about and
you have to kind of really do that every
day they just want then you won't watch
it and then once people see your movie
they really love it because I really did
love your moving really did and so about
other people need to know that because
they just won't unless you literally
have to go to people now it's like in
the past it used to be that people just
find stuff there's just so much stuff to
find now that you get buried in just in
a maze of content
you